we've said so many impressive responses
to the challenges to the few challenges
we've put out there that we to some
degree want to see if we can just have
more people creating and putting out
ideas and kind of taking ourselves out
of the equation and so what we've set up
here is a little bit of a little Google
moderator the link is here I'll also
make it an annotation to this video that
you can click on and i'll put the link
in the description of this video and the
general idea here is for anyone to go to
this this this google moderator thing
put ideas up for for computer science
projects or for programming projects and
other people can vote them up or down
based on how badly they want someone to
work on this and then if you are able to
build one of these things you can post a
response and put your link to the thing
that you actually created and so I'm
really I've already populated with a few
things that I would like to see but you
know we should just all vote for
whatever we all want to see the most and
see what people create and I'm really
excited to see what might happen here